We have the makings of a new ultra scandal
for Donald Trump.
It is one where I can sum it up really concisely
and that is corruption at the highest level.
Donald Trump has now fired four inspectors
general in the last few weeks.
The entire I'm taking Hydroxy chloroquine
gambit may even be a sort of semi deliberate
attempt to take attention away, actually,
from some of the things Trump is doing.
And we've talked before about the question,
what point is there in having inspectors general
if Trump can just fire them when they're looking
into something he doesn't want them looking
into?
In case in point, it appears that Donald Trump's
firing of Inspector General Steve Linnik was
specifically because Linnik was investigating
a US sale of weapons to Saudi Arabia that
was fast tracked by Trump Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo under the auspices of Trump, declaring
the situation with Iran an emergency back
in twenty nineteen.
Now, this is the type of story that doesn't
get a lot of coverage.
It doesn't get a lot of views.
I would be shocked if this story does well
on our YouTube channel or on Facebook.
But it is alleged scandal at the highest level
because the official statement was Linnik
was fired because he wasn't performing his
job.
Well, that's what Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said.
There are now numerous lawmakers, even some
Republicans, saying this doesn't make sense.
This doesn't pass the sniff test.
This was all to cover up a dirty arms deal
with Saudi Arabia to get around congressional
approval of that deal.
So the allegation goes that back in twenty
nineteen, Trump made an emergency declaration
specifically to clear the path for eight billion
dollars in military arms sales to Saudi Arabia
and United Arab Emirates.
The emergency declaration was with regards
to Iran.
The goal was, as the story is being alleged,
that by declaring an emergency, the arms deal
doesn't need congressional review.
In fact, both the House and Senate passed
resolutions blocking the sale.
But Trump vetoed the resolutions and kept
the sale going with this emergency declaration.
We even have Republicans concerned, like Senator
Chuck Grassley, that the explanation for why
I.G.
Linnik was fired isn't making any sense.
So admittedly, we're just at the start of
this.
We only have a sort of cloudy picture of what
went on.
It could be much worse than what I'm telling
you.
It could be different.
There could be more to it.
But it is also in the mix that Mike Pompeo
was refusing to cooperate with Disinvested
investigation by I.G.
Linnik.
And we've since found out that as part of
his investigation, the I.G.
Started looking at claims that Mike Pompeo
was doing things like, for example, having
State Department employees walk his dog, pick
up his dry cleaning and make dinner reservations
completely outside the scope.
Of course, that would be something that he
should hire some kind of personal staff for
not use, says State Department staff.
So this could be as simple as Pompei wanted
to get Linnik out of the way because Linnik
was looking into Pompei O's dog walking misuse
of staff time.
It could be way worse in that it was part
of a bigger conspiracy to get around congressional
approval to do an arms deal.
But there are a whole bunch of big corruption
stories here.
And first, the facts of what went on with
this specific arms deal and emergency declaration
and the I.G.
Firing in the investigation that needs to
be figured out.
That's this story.
Number two is the ongoing hypocrisy of Republicans
with regard to i.g.'s in general under Obama.
Many of the same Republicans that now stand
aside as Trump fires I.G.
After I.G.
A lot of those same Republicans when it was
Barack Obama were saying we need to empower
inspectors general and we need to make sure
that a president can't get rid of them.
They are silent now.
And these I.G.
Firings.
So far, we don't this one, we're still figuring
out have been clear political retaliations.
And then lastly, there's just the sniff test,
as I like to call it.
You don't fire for inspectors general in a
few weeks.
Under normal circumstances, Trump is taking
apart every oversight mechanism that we have
and he's getting away with it.
Trump will say, listen, these i.g.'s were
never Trump Burse.
They were tools of the left and he'll get
away with it.
Enough people hate Democrats on principle
so much that they will let him get away away
with it.
Call it brainwashing.
Call it hyper partisanship.
Whatever you call it.
He's getting away with it unless we vote him
out in just a
few months.